coucou mon chat
[Musique]
c'était un collègue
et puis petit à petit l'amitié c'est
muet
en une relation amoureuse et très très
vite
on a eu un désir de d'enfants sachant
qu'on avait tous les deux des enfants
d'une d'une première union
quand je suis tombée enceinte où ils
allaient sur ces quatre ans
et 27 décembre 2018 du coup
comme un cadeau de Noël Timothée est né
c'était une naissance incroyable
qui s'est fait tout en douceur
Timothée c'est un bébé
très doux et se souvenir de
sa douceur de la douceur de sa peau de
la douceur de ses petits cheveux
il faisait des sourires
et j'avais l'impression qu'il avait
toute la sagesse du monde dans ses yeux
[Musique]
le 28 février 2019 je vais en
rendez-vous chez maquinée en fait et je
laisse Timothée à la maison avec son
papa je fais
dernier bisou à Timothée m'a fait un
sourire
et puis je pars à mon rendez-vous
[Musique]
partant du rendez-vous
ben j'envoie un texto pour savoir si
tout se passe bien si Timothée s'est
rendormi si il y a pas de souci
et c'est là que
le papa me dit qu'il est à l'hôpital
[Musique]
et donc là je panique
et donc
je cours à l'hôpital
[Musique]
on pense qu'en France il y a plusieurs
centaines peut-être 4500 cas
diagnostiqués par an mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que
il y a aussi des enfants qui sont
secoués et dont l'état clinique n'est
pas suffisamment grave pour qu'il soit
amené à l'hôpital donc pour moi je suis
persuadée qu'il y a beaucoup plus de cas
qu'on ne pense de bébé secoué
je retrouve le papa de Timothée
qui est devant une porte Timothée
allongé sur sur une table
qui m'inquiète énormément c'est que
j'essaye tout de suite d'établir un
contact visuel avec lui et en fait c'est
impossible il a les yeux ouverts mais
[Musique]
il accroche pas le regard il a les yeux
qui partent dans tous les sens
j'ai plus cette connexion avec mon bébé
et je vois qu'il souffre en fait et je
peux rien faire
[Musique]
ce qui va se
une situation de gravité effectivement
qui était en train de se présenter voilà
avec des paramètres cliniques un SCOP
qui nous présentait beaucoup de
paramètres
voilà qui qui tous cumulé alors qui
séparément pouvait être expliqué par de
la fièvre ou autre mais là on avait
vraiment le tableau complet de l'extrême
gravité
lui font passer le scanner on remonte et
là cette même médecin à qui j'avais posé
la question de
la survie de Timothée
nous convoque dans un
petit bureau et là elle nous dit
que le scanner a montré qu'il y avait
des hématomes soudureaux et que c'est le
syndrome du bébé secoué
donc le diagnostic est posé tout de
suite
et ce gougouement c'est un geste d'une
extrême violence ça entraîne chez
l'enfant une mouvement de la tête très
brutal en hyper flexion en hyper
extension et d'ailleurs on ne serait
parlé de de syndrome de la tête secouée
puisque en fait ce qui compte c'est le
mouvement de la tête par rapport au
corps de l'enfant donc il y a des
mouvements qui sont qui s'opposent et
donc dans ces il y a à ce moment-là une
rupture de de veine pont alors les
veines Pons ce sont des veines qui
drainent tout le sang veineux du cerveau
donc comme lésion il y a rupture de
venne pont il y a hématome sudur à
multifocal il peut y avoir aussi de la
même manière que le cerveau est secoué
l'oeil et secouer donc on peut avoir des
hémorragies rétiniennes au fond de l'œil
[Musique]
à l'hôpital Necker et c'était
à 5 jours d'enfer en fait
sauf que
il y a eu deux petites fées
qui était là
il y avait l'infirmière de jour soit
l'infirmière de nuit claire et ça a été
un petit baume un petit peu de lumière
dans toute cette noirceur en fait
[Musique]
qui va pas s'en sortir au vu de la
gravité de la situation au vu de ce
qu'on voit aussi bien des paramètres que
de sa clinique
donc c'est déjà ce qu'on va devoir
annoncer à ses parents on commence déjà
nous intérieurement à se préparer à tout
ça
moi je m'accroche
à cet espoir que Timothée va vivre et
que les médecins vont me sauver et un
des médecins me dit mais madame
quand bien même on arriverait à le
sauver
le cerveau de Timothée est tellement
endommagé que il pourrait avoir de
relation avec de relation sociale avec
personne
et je lui dis mais
moi je m'en fous tant qu'il en a avec
moi
et là il me regarde et il me dit
[Musique]
un traumatisme crânien de et
particulièrement grave si l'enfant est
tout petit parce que les neurones enfin
on a un stock de neurones à la naissance
mais on en a plus d'autres c'est à dire
que chaque fois que des neurones sont
détruits finalement après il faut faire
avec avec ce qui reste donc l'enfant si
des neurones sont détruits par les
secoumants et bien plus tard il aura il
devra se développer avec les neurones
qui lui reste et c'est ce qui explique
la fréquence des séquelles et leur
gravité et le fait qu'elle dure toute la
vie
les médecins me disent que la pression
crânienne est beaucoup trop importante
que l'opération n'a pas réussi à la
faire baisser
à un niveau acceptable et que simplement
mon bébé en fait est complètement
[Musique]
on retourne en chambre
je me retrouve seule avec Aude
qui au départ et
silencieuse mutique le regard dans le
vide
et au bout d'un moment
et Soizic
je comprends ce qui s'est passé je
comprends ce que ce que vous m'avez dit
je comprends que ça puisse pas être
autre chose
je sais ce que j'ai pas fait
donc par élimination
ça je sais voilà je
sais ce qui a dû être je devine ce qu'il
y a dû se passer mais c'est pas possible
il a pas pu faire ça choisis que c'est
pas possible
je vais lui des histoires
je vais dire au revoir
en fait je lui ai dit que
j'étais d'accord pour qu'ils sont
mariés et en fait la température a
commencé à
à baisser
toute seule
comme si lui aussi il a fait
quand
[Musique]
il m'a fallu survivre et quand j'ai
survivre ça veut dire
me lever sortir de mon lit
m'alimenter être capable de sortir de
chez moi
[Musique]
c'est au début j'y arrivais pas et ça ça
a duré longtemps
j'ai appris
à faire partie de ce monde
à m'occuper de Louise et effectivement à
lire tout ce que je pouvais et
comprendre cette maltraitance du
syndrome du bébé secoué
[Musique]
c'est malheureusement beaucoup trop
notre quotidien en réanimation ça allait
encore plus depuis deux ans puisque
depuis deux ans effectivement il y a eu
le cet énorme pandémie mondiale avec le
covid qui
on a très clairement vu une forte
augmentation effectivement de des
secousses entre 10 et 20% des bébés
décèdent ce qui est bien plus que dans
un traumatisme crânien accidentel donc
il y a une forte mortalité une forte
morbidité aussi puisque plus de trois
quarts à trois quarts des enfants qui
survivent présentent des séquelles et
c'est quel intellectuel des séquelles
comportementales des séquelles motrices
des séquelles visuels qui vont garder
toute leur vie forcément c'est quelque
chose qui est pas anodin c'est quelque
chose qui impacte beaucoup les équipes
je me suis pris comme une claque
notamment la première fois que j'ai pris
en charge un bébé secoué
et puis deux et puis trois et puis 10
et là en fait
ça a généré beaucoup d'émotions parce
que je me suis dit ben je suis arrivée
avec plein d'idées en fait par là je
peux rien faire
j'accueille tous ces enfants mais c'est
déjà trop tard
et donc j'ai commencé voilà ça a
commencé à germer un petit peu dans ma
tête cette envie de vouloir faire
quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est rester un petit peu comme ça en
stand-by jusqu'à ce que me recontacte
et là voilà ça juste chamboulé beaucoup
de choses déjà parce que
émotionnellement ça pue
[Musique]
avec Soizic
on avait pas besoin de se parler c'est
au final peu parler je crois
et en fait il suffisait qu'on se regarde
pour se comprendre
[Musique]
si tu avais pas été là
ça aurait été encore pire enfin
j'ai quand même
avec un peu de temps maintenant
une vente de douceur en fait associé un
jour
c'est juste l'enfer
et
quand tu étais là c'était
aussi c'est comme si tu me disais
ça va aller quand même quoi
au fur et à mesure moi mon combat
avance et
du coup oui mais l'idée qu'effectivement
elle doit faire partie de ce combat là
parce que je sais qu'elle prend en
charge beaucoup de bébés secoués et elle
fait partie de l'histoire de Timothée
voilà en tout cas déjà qu'on en parle
encore
on en parle systématiquement déjà en
termes de prévention en fait on en parle
pas assez on en parle pas ou très peu ne
serait-ce que sur les ressortis de
maternité parce que parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de d'équipes professionnelles
qui disent à bol mais tu comprends ils
viennent d'être parents ils sont tous
meilleurs c'est un peu triste de parler
de ça ah bah ouais ce sera un peu plus
triste quand il passera cinq jours ici
en fait
globalement aujourd'hui la prévention
c'est très très inégal en fait il y a
certaines maternités qui font
des super choses et à côté de ça on a on
a d'autres maternités ou et ben on en
parle pas du tout donc c'est hyper
inégal et moi c'est ça aussi mon combat
c'est de
faire en sorte que demain aucun parent
ne sorte d'une maternité sans avoir eu
un échange sur le syndrome du bébé
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous c'est pas une
professionnelle de santé je suis une
maman d'un petit Timothée qui est décédé
parce qu'il a été secoué et depuis je
je suis devenue un peu militante pour
qu'on parle le premier frein qui fait
que il y a pas de
systématiquement de la prévention
il vient des professionnels de santé
même et ça c'est ce frein là
on peut facilement le lever en réalité
c'est en formant
tous les professionnels de santé sur ce
sujet du syndrome du bébé se connaît
et enfin le dernier chiffre qui fait
froid dans le dos c'est dix fois c'est à
dire que c'est une maltraitance qui est
répétée
les bébés qui sont diagnostiqués avec le
syndrome du bébé secoué ont été en
moyenne secouer 10 fois
je suis au quotidien confrontée assez
10% de bébé qui décède tous les jours
donc c'est un sujet
et pour lequel effectivement j'ai envie
de me battre un petit peu chaque jour au
quotidien et en ayant une formation
puéricultrice
la prévention pour moi c'est un acte qui
me tient énormément à cœur
il y a peut-être 20 ans on disait c'est
un coup de tonnerre dans le ciel sera
c'est-à-dire on imaginait l'adulte
exténué exaspéré qui entre guillemets
péter les plombs prenez l'enfant et le
secouer comme un prunier pour le faire
taire
[Musique]
ça supposait que l'enfant pleurait
beaucoup et puis ça supposait que ça
n'arrivait qu'une fois
si c'était vraiment un craquage ce
serait les mères qui secouraient parce
que c'est elle qui sont le plus souvent
enfin le plus avec l'enfant là je suis
un peu
tombé de ma chaise parce que je me suis
rendu compte qu'en réalité c'était les
pères qui secouaient les bébés en
majorité donc et là je me suis dit mais
personne en parle en fait personne en
parle et ce tabou ça fait qu'on se
raconte un truc qui qui acceptable et
c'est cette belle histoire où on se dit
c'est un parent qui est vraiment à bout
qui est épuisé c'est un accident tu vois
en fait tu en arrives à dire c'est un
accident alors que non c'est une
maltraitance
c'est un face à face entre l'adulte et
le bébé
c'est moi l'adulte qui commande je fais
ce que je veux de toi et tu vas
m'écouter
et tu vas m'obéir et tu vas surtout
arrêter de m'emmerder en fait c'est
un sujet effectivement hyper important
et je suis d'accord en fait je pense
qu'on pourrait
faire au moins une session collage sur
le sujet alors du coup je sais pas si
toi tu as des un message à faire passer
en particulier par exemple je sais pas
si par exemple nous on pour les
féminicides donc il y a quelque chose
qu'on fait
qu'on trouve hyper important et très
fort c'est d'essayer de rendre le nom
des femmes en fait mais ça oui pour le
rendre leur humanité donc par exemple
ton fils qui ne pourrait pas les oublier
en fait c'est pas les oublier en fait
[Musique]
non il y a aussi bébé secouer et tuer
bébé secoué et tué
[Musique]
attention parce que du coup ça reprend
il faut être sur le blanc
moi je suis quand même hyper
impressionnée par votre rapidité et la
régularité dans vos lettres enfin ça se
voit que vous avez l'habitude c'est
en fait c'est pas un cas isolé
malheureusement
il fait partie d'une très longue liste
et ça donc
je l'ai découvert au fur et à mesure en
fait il y a beaucoup plus de bébés
secoué que ce qu'on imagine
donc voilà il y a un moment je me suis
dit mais
ça peut pas continuer comme ça
selon les statistiques que nous avons à
disposition 70% des auteurs de bébé
secoués sont des hommes donc 50% pour
les paires 20% pour les compagnons des
mères c'est surprenant que ce soit
d'abord les hommes qui se coulent les
bébés puisqu'il faut savoir qu'il
s'occupe deux fois moins des enfants que
les femmes et pourtant ce sont eux qui
secouent dans l'immense majorité des cas
les bébés on va changer une dynamique de
couple on va passer de la conjugalité à
la parentalité il y a une jalousie mais
qui se pose à plusieurs niveaux il y a
une jalousie vis-à-vis de sa compagne il
y a une jalousie vis-à-vis de l'enfant
il y a une jalousie en lien à la perte
j'ai perdu une qualité dans la
conjugalité et la paisibilité avec ma
compagne mais il faut réussir à en faire
le deuil
et effectivement il y avait des
voilà il a eu il a eu des réflexions
me disant mais toute façon maintenant
moi je ne les mets que plus parce qu'on
avait Timothée
maintenant on connaît mieux qui sont les
auteurs mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
secoué
quel est le mécanisme psychologique ou
qui les a qui les a conduit à secouer on
sait pas trop
[Musique]
coup de pied c'est pas autorisé coup de
tête c'est pas autorisé coup de poing
c'est pas autorisé
je le secoue je suis énervé il
m'exaspère je n'en peux plus il est
dévalorisant il me déçoit en plus il me
fait honte je le prends je le secoue en
plus quand je le secoue ici je le repose
et en plus plus tard il va même pas s'en
souvenir
ça c'est autant de petits éléments qui
peuvent être des déclencheurs du passage
à l'acte
quand j'entends que le ce comment d'un
enfant est causé par des pleurs
je peux pas m'empêcher de faire le
parallèle avec l'époque où on pouvait
dire que le viol était causé par un
habillement un peu trop
attrayant pour pour l'auteur du viol
finalement le pleure ne cause pas plus
le secouement qu'une mini jupe va causer
un viol
[Musique]
dans l'éducation qu'on donne aux garçons
il y a une acculturation à la violence
notamment qui passe par la transmission
de valeur viril et finalement c'est pour
cette raison donc par une construction
sociale finalement que les hommes en
viennent à être les premiers
responsables de la violence
[Musique]
rose était avec moi pendant deux mois et
demi le temps du congé maternité
classique en France
donc au bout de trois mois je dois
reprendre le travail donc du coup je me
suis retrouvé à chercher une
on l'a recrute en fait
via une amie à nous qui a son fils qui
est chez elle depuis
quasiment neuf mois 8 mois
qui a de très très bonnes références
elle avait le diplôme d'auxiliaire
depuis la culture depuis 10 ans
elle avait déjà gardé plusieurs enfants
tout se passait bien donc du coup je la
rencontre je sens que il y a le feeling
il y a pas de souci particulier son
domicile et c'était vraiment une mini
crèche totalement adaptée aux enfants
c'est vrai que quand on voit ça de
l'extérieur on se dit mon enfant va être
bien chez cette personne
[Musique]
oui qu'elle est belle ma chérie d'amour
tu es belle ma poupée
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
on la pose le matin
sans problème particulier
et à 15h17 mon mari m'appelle pour me
dire que
que est pris en charge par le Samu
et qu'il fallait que on aille maintenant
un écart quoi et en arrivant là-bas
le matin me dit que madame je ne sais
pas ce qui se passe encore pour votre
fille la seule chose que je peux vous
dire c'est que l'état de votre fille
ne correspond pas avec ce que nous
raconte ça nous
au départ elle n'avoue pas elle reste
très confuse sur la chute probable chute
parce qu'elle raconte jusqu'à présent
elle racontait ça
[Musique]
on connaît les lésions du syndrome du
bébé secoué et on connaît les histoires
apportées par l'adulte alors le jeu le
manque d'oxygène le l'accouchement le
grand frère
la chute les vaccins il y a beaucoup de
beaucoup d'imagination de la part des
des auteurs
events c'est quelque chose de très
solide donc il faut imprimer une force
très très importante on compare en fait
la force à imprimer
au cerveau de l'enfant à un accident de
la route à 160 km heure
je crois que la première nuit à l'aube
de cette première nuit de garde à vue
elle a elle avoue
elle a vu qu'elle a fait du mal à la
rose
elle a vu qu'elle l'a
secoué
[Musique]
20% d'assistante maternelle dans les
personnes susceptibles de secouer c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup parce que c'est
un mode de garde qui est quand même
développé en France donc je pense qu'il
faudrait prendre conscience de
l'importance de que joue ces femmes
auprès de ses enfants
et peut-être
mettre plus de garde-fous pour éviter un
risque de passage à l'acte quand on
connaît un petit peu ce domaine on se
rend compte finalement que il y a
peut-être pas assez de cadres
pas assez de protection pour l'enfant et
finalement pas assez de reconnaissance
non plus de ce métier et on confie des
enfants à des personnes qui devraient
pas être amenés en garder
le premier jour du procès s'ouvre
et là c'est
très difficile parce qu'on se replonge
trois ans en arrière
tout est décortiqué avec énormément de
détails sur les détails de ce qu'avec
eux roses là c'était insupportable j'ai
pas pu rester
en maternelle
en peine de justification
expliquer qu'elle s'était sentie comme
posséder on était après le repas donc
rose était très certainement fatigué
c'était l'heure de la sieste elle le
savait elle l'a dit et rose à peine
à peine un tel commencé
à pleurer donc au bout de quelques
secondes elle s'est levée et elle a
foncé sur rose et elle a elle a subi
cette petite un déferlement de violence
[Musique]
quand on apprend qu'elle prend 15 ans
on
crois qu'on est tellement tous
[Musique]
choqué qu'elle prenne autant parce que
on connaît les peines malheureusement
en fait on a pas réagi
on est resté
bon il fallait aussi
il fallait mais on est resté stoïque et
là j'ai compris qu'elle avait vraiment
pris 15 ans en fait
j'ai regardé nos avocats
et j'ai pleuré parce que je me suis dit
ça elle est condamnée
c'est une peine extrêmement lourde
qui a été qui a été prononcé si on la
rapporte au thème habituellement
prononcé dans ce type de carte
[Musique]
après la mort de rose ça a été très très
dur vraiment
on a vraiment passé de très très mauvais
moments et honnêtement
quand on vit ça
[Musique]
soit on décide d'avancer et de vivre et
non pas de survivre
soit la vie ne vous plus la peine
donc
[Musique]
et donc on choisit la vie
et on a dit que on s'est décidé
à refaire des enfants
[Musique]
mais je sais aussi que tout ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui on n'a pas pu le vivre
avec Rose donc on le vit
non pas avec elle mais pour elle
[Musique]
ça va
ben oui je te suis
[Musique]
quelques jours avant je voulais pas y
aller ah oui avant mais une fois qu'il a
commencé une fois qu'il a commencé bah
j'étais dedans donc et le après aussi
est dur ça m'a rien du tout le dire
faire
trois ans que mon fils est décédé et
il se passe rien
c'est comme si
comme si on s'en foutait qu'il soit mort
en fait à peine enfin moi j'étais déçu
déjà je m'attendais au moins 10 ans et
finalement il a pris 6 c'est peu mais en
même temps je me dis c'est quand même 6
ans enfin à la base ils sont mon avocat
il demandait du sursis s'il te plaît
sur je te dis mais comment tu peux
donner du sursis à une personne qui a
tué son enfant on a l'impression que
cette violence qui est le syndrome du
bébé secoué est encore banalisé et
finalement on se rend compte que dans
cette affaire en particulier
on n'a pas pris conscience de la
violence qui se jouait et on n'a pas
pris conscience non plus de la gravité
du résultat
tu vas aller défendre je sais pas ton
mari ou
toi
même pas de tu vois de circonstances
atténuantes ah non non direct c'est ça
qui me dit effectivement voilà que vaut
la vie d'un bébé est-ce que ça a la même
valeur pour pour la justice que c'est ce
que
je me suis dit ouais en fait et je l'ai
d'ailleurs dit mon avocate j'ai
l'impression que mon fils est mort pour
rien ça sert vraiment il est mort parce
que on l'a secoué pour rien pour rien
juste parce qu'on voulait lui voter la
vie en fait juste comme ça allez hop les
idées reçues bien sûr on des
conséquences importantes au niveau des
tribunaux parce que
si on a comme idée reçue que tout le
monde est susceptible de secouer un
enfant et que finalement la cause du
secouement c'est pas propre à l'auteur
mais c'est dû aux pleurs de l'enfant
incessant que l'auteur n'a plus
supporter on a en fait de l'empathie
pour l'auteur on s'identifie à lui et
donc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
sanctionner sévèrement une personne à
qui on s'identifie par contre si tu
tailles tout genre
je savais que Maëlle avait la colonne
vertébrale de toucher donc c'est là en
fait où je me suis dit ouais en fait
j'ai bien fait de enfin je l'ai pas
vraiment débranché mais j'ai bien fait
de tout arrêter en fait
la colonne vertébrale de toucher dont la
moelle épinière c'est mort n'aurait
jamais marché enfin jamais pu parler
jamais rien
et là je me suis dit waouh il y a pas
tellement morte quand même pour toucher
la moelle épinard la colonne vertébrale
c'est que la brisé en fait totalement
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
la violence du geste de ce comment de
savoir ce que c'est de savoir que ce
coin un enfant c'est pas lui faire faire
l'avion
le bercé un peu trop fort l'auteur à
l'enfant face à lui il voit la tête de
se nourrisson qui justement et donc
considéré dans dans
l'idée commune comme fragile il voit
cette tête balotée à une vitesse folle
d'avant en arrière avec des coûts et des
contrecoups extrêmement fort avec
peut-être en plus un visuel en face à
face sur les yeux de l'enfant qui qui
vit un moment effrayant ça aggrave sa
culpabilité
tu as une peluche ou quoi de ton fils
dit que j'avais un peu de colère tu vois
du crispation parce que c'était le cas
je tenais une doudou de mon système en
fait tu vas penser qu'à Timothée
j'arrive pas à me préparer
moi c'est ma vie qui a été bousillé
c'est
toute ma vie qui a volé en éclate ce
jour-là mon fils est mort je peux pas me
préparer une peine légère
ça serait pas en fait ça serait même pas
respectueux pour mon fils le problème
c'est que
dans la tête de certains jurés
le fait de plus avoir son enfant c'est
une peine en soi c'est déjà une peine et
du coup de leur mettre de la de la peine
encore plus de prison c'est pire mais
soit tu es en prison pour toute ta vie
en fait
j'ai honte que ça soit mon compagnon qui
l'ai fait parce que j'ai aimé cette
personne du plus profond de mon cœur
vraiment j'étais vraiment amoureuse de
lui j'étais parti pour me marier avec
lui pour moi c'était l'homme de ma vie
donc j'ai honte de cette personne j'ai
honte que ce soit mon compagnon et j'ai
honte parce que c'est moi la maman et
que je n'ai pas vu
et que si j'avais su bien sûr que je
serais parti
donc oui à ce moment là je ressens une
terrible honte
j'ai un projet de faire une PMA qui est
en cours d'ailleurs
parce que c'est viscéral pour moi
en tout cas je fais un enfant toute
seule et je pense que c'est la meilleure
solution
c'est impossible pour moi de faire
confiance à un homme alors bien sûr j'ai
envie de rencontrer quelqu'un comme
toute femme mais
avoir des projets d'enfance je suis pas
possible je ne pourrais pas laisser mon
enfant à un homme c'est
en tout cas mon compagnon en tout cas ce
sera j'aurais jamais confiance
[Musique]
plus grande que papa
avant j'imaginais pas grand chose
de ce qui m'arriverait après en fait
c'est à dire que j'étais assez naïf et
j'ai pensé que j'arriverai à concilier
ma vie d'avant avec la vie de d'après
[Musique]
il y a un petit rond
il y a des papas qui ont des enfants des
papas qui en ont pas encore la majorité
attend son bébé le rôle événement donc
c'est très bien il y a un côté donc
information il y a un côté
éventuellement d'exercice notamment sur
de le thème un des thèmes c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est énervé
que le bébé pleure et qu'on n'en peux
plus et qu'on rentre du boulot voilà
donc on s'y on partage les expériences
et éventuellement des infos aussi
pratiques
oui c'est comme lipovigible des parents
on est formé à tout dans la vie sauf à
la parentalité il y a des choses pour
les mamans mais il y a très peu de
choses pour les papas du moment où j'ai
vu ma fille la première fois j'ai croisé
son petit coin deuil c'est important qui
est des groupes de papa fait aussi avec
des interventions d'hommes eux-mêmes
papa j'en suis un j'ai trois enfants
voilà et donc c'est c'est clairement une
cible qui a été visée avec bienveillance
pour les faut vraiment travailler en
amont des drames du syndrome du bébé
square dans les cinq premiers jours je
sais pas si ça peut aider mais en tout
cas ce que le niveau de décrites les
deux premiers jours ont été très
tranquille on s'est dit fantastique ce
petit ça va être un moine bouddhiste
la troisième ligne ça a été absolument
horrible mais en fait juste d'être
préparé à ça
ben ça ce que je n'étais pas forcément
ça enlève cette colère ça enlève cette
frustration et au moins on sait que
façon la nuit est foutue c'est pas la
peine
voilà juste pour le petit témoignage de
ce que j'ai pu sentir
voilà c'est le sentiment aussi qu'il
faut accepter que ça arrive il y a des
moments un peu comme les cris qui
rendent fou aussi c'est alors il faut
gérer ça c'est important et ça c'est
vraiment un truc on en avait parlé avant
la naissance de la gestion de l'émotion
par rapport à ça
je dois confesser qu'un peu moi je me
disais bon ça va je
et non non il y a vraiment des moments
j'en pouvais plus c'était dur donc là on
se calme on posait enfant on laisse un
peu redescendre il peut rien arriver
et ainsi que ça va aller
alors non dire que il faut pas secouer
un bébé c'est pas suffisant mais déjà de
le dire quand même de parler du fait que
que des bébés
s'ils sont secoués ils vont mourir ou
seront handicapés à vie
peut-être que déjà
c'est un premier
un premier moyen parce que
l'adulte qui secoue c'est qu'il a que
c'est pas bien ce qu'il est en train de
faire pour autant est-ce qu'il sait qui
peut tuer l'enfant
donc le rappeler rappeler quand même que
ce coin un bébé peut le tuer ou
l'handicapé à vie et quand on parle de
handicap ça peut être des handicaps très
très lourds je pense que ça c'est pas
inutile de le rappeler
[Musique]
le groupe de papa auquel j'ai participé
ça a été quelque chose de très utile
très utile qu'il faudrait absolument
généraliser parce que je pense qu'il y a
une demande
j'ai dû faire 4 séances et
on se rencontre entre père novice et
père jeune père
dans le feu de la bataille et ça nous
prépare bien
un bébé c'est des responsabilités en
plus voir des perturbations dans la
relation entre le papa et sa compagne ce
sont des pauses qui va se retrouver très
vite et naturellement elle accaparait
par le bébé qui vient de naître mais du
coup voilà ça fait un déséquilibre entre
la vie avant le bébé et la vie après le
bébé et quand le bébé est là et comment
se prépare à ça c'est très important
pour ne pas prendre le bébé comme un
élément perturbateur au final
une fois j'ai fait une crise de nerfs
qui a été assez impressionnante c'est la
première fois que ça m'est arrivé c'est
à dire que je me sentais tellement
impuissant
rien pouvoir faire pour aider la maman
le bébé
plus la fatigue le travail le stress du
boulot qui mine de rien travailler dans
ma tête c'est qu'à un moment donné j'ai
ouais j'ai craqué quoi j'ai craqué je
suis allé à côté je me suis effondré en
larmes
le plus important est de prendre
conscience de la montée de la colère et
si on veut être précis c'est que la
colère c'est pas un gros paquet rouge
c'est que ça commence par un tout petit
point laser rouge et on apprend à
identifier l'apparition de ce point qui
va grandir grandir grandir donc c'est un
travail global sur l'impulsivité
et sur la météo des émotions c'est
vraiment ça la prévention en fait
quelque part on disant
intellectuellement c'est cette question
qu'on pose quelle place êtes-vous prêt à
faire à ce bébé et comment avez-vous
vous êtes vous préparer à lui laisser
une place j'ai des moments de stupeur où
je la regarde je me dis c'est
hallucinant je comprends pas ce qui
m'arrive de
peut-être je me dis quand je joue elle
m'appellera papa là ce sera vraiment
pliez vraiment pour de bon mais je
trouve ça très étrange comme en petit à
petit on s'investit de ce rôle là c'est
pas un truc comme ça plus c'est bon bébé
est né c'est le temps qu'on passe pour
ce petit être qui fait que voilà il est
il est il est à sa place unique quoi
c'est clair
[Musique]
je vis en apnée en attendant le procès
parce que
parce que j'ai besoin que
que la mort de mon fils
soit reconnu
[Musique]
c'est un peu ma thérapie en fait cet
engagement
on va essayer de transformer en fait
tout le chagrin et
toute la tristesse et
voilà le transformer en une action qui
soit positive
et puis qui je l'espère va aider
à sauver des bébés éviter à d'autres
familles de connaître le drame que j'ai
vécu
[Musique]
ce que veut dire